but first another source of chaos is of
course our trains four in five Services
were canceled today as 40
000 rmt workers walked out and malls to
come with passengers expected to face
five days of misery this week but the
rmt boss yes Mick Lynch he said from a
picket line this morning that the
government know what they need to do to
reach a settlement
well we're out on strike again this
morning in pursuit of the settlement the
government and the companies have not
put any fresh proposals to us they know
what needs to be done to move towards a
settlement how to work through the
problems and get to some documentation
that we could all support but that's not
happened so far we're hoping in the next
few days that they will come to us and
propose more meetings and more sessions
of negotiations but at the moment that's
simply not there the government has let
these strikes go ahead and that's
unfortunate but that seems to be their
position at this time
well joining us now is former rmt
assistant general secretary Steve
Headley thanks for joining us today I
mean these strikes are going nowhere are
they don't seem to be making any
progress
well I mean look the reality is
privatization has been an absolute
disaster and we have the worst of all
worlds nowhere the government's really
uh getting the train operating countries
companies to manage the system rather
than actually run it the government are
interfering in the negotiations in a
negative way and really if you you did
your sort of neo-fascist resume of where
the country is bringing the Army
well yeah you brought me on to get my
opinion so there you go um and we we
have a situation where capitalism isn't
working we've got the NHS in crisis
because it's been under yeah but we're
heads
let's talk about the rmt where the
medium pay of your members is about
about just under 40 000 about 38 000
pounds so quite significantly above how
much how much are you on
we're not on strike but nobody nobody
would notice if you did go on strike
would they well well
I'll tell you what would happen What
would happen if we went to strike is
that we'd be replaced and the point is
that the rmt members they're essentially
holding they're holding the whole
country to Ransom which I can't but oh
really you know I know you're reading
everything off your order Kudo because
you just standing for
and they're the ones that are stopping
the negotiations the government are the
ones who are preventing the train
operating companies come to an agreement
with the rmt so they're holding the
country around some not the unions so
where's your original solution to this
problem my solution is to give people an
inflation pay raise that's not original
sorry that's not original you said that
we had nothing to original to say well
yeah you asked me a question
no okay then well let's let's have a
complete change of the economic system
that we have let's have workers councils
take control in the country uh see how
your army get on then yeah that's
communism
is that original enough no one's
communism in this country realistic what
we want is our public services for which
we're paying ever on our taxes to work
so we've got we've got this sort of uh
you know the the variation of a British
fascist party rollout in front of us who
want to bring in the army
if you were listening you would have
heard that the context of the army
suggestion was the NHS although I have
to say I suspect that the Army would do
a better job of running the railways
than is being done right now I suspect
Colonel because it's a better job than
you know
let's try and be positive shall we Steve
as opposed to negative it is the new
year after all so you want an inflation
link pay increase what about the
productivity Improvement as opposed to
the old archaic Spanish working
practices that exists
work and practice well for example
um you have to sort of decide voluntary
working on Sundays for example
the property managers in Houston can't
do some Property Management maintenance
in Saint Pancras because it's too far to
walk they work for different companies
they didn't work
do something for ATV upstairs because
you don't work for them so you don't
want a different region so you just want
more more pay but with no productivity
improvements whatsoever that's not a
realistic world that everybody loves the
realistic world is you and your Mets who
you actually help you come on here as
repeaters for have cut massive uh tax
breaks you're offshore and money
um
Steve you have no idea I'm talking about
I'm talking about the rich in this
country are you trying to say that
doesn't happen hang on a minute you were
talking about us too no we're talking
about your words
yes you have something I've even got
something offshored as well absolutely
nothing
although Frankie had quite liked it yeah
I bet you would yes I would because I
my taxes are well used in this country
and I thoroughly why would you leave I
thoroughly why don't you stop why do you
stop why do you assume I've got mates
in the system
the reality is
your money aren't you nonsense
all you want to do is you want more cash
for ever worse Services I think people
are happy to pay for proper decency
you understand you understand right do
you understand that the money that the
government are paying the train
operating companies is actually getting
paid out to shareholders do you
understand that's where it's going I do
hundreds and I've said I've said to your
colleague I've said to your colleague
and I agree with you I agree with you
you shouldn't be sending money the
reality reality is right that if that
money wasn't paid out this year holders
and it was paid right that if people had
actually run the railway as long as they
run them properly efficiently into a
timely fashion like happens in
Switzerland all right if that money was
paid to the workers instead of the
shareholders there wouldn't be a problem
with that but you've got to have modern
contemporary working practices
like you've got that's right yeah we
work in the past sector yeah and look
it's working out fairly well for you
isn't it well I'll tell you what a while
in the road
no one's at work it is a private sector
in the railways have you not understood
that have you not understood that the
states
I want to help you find a solution oh
you seem like it I do but you don't seem
to want to talk about productivity too
well don't worry we'll talk about some
modern day practices one that helps the
industry no one else in no one else in
the UK has gas now you know when I can
speak well I'm just asking you a
question
Beyond here to explain position but
you're not giving no what you've
actually done would you would you like
would you like me to speak
I frankly I'm not sure what's going to
come out of your mouth because well
we're in a similar situation
oh I see that top there on the autocue
you sat there and you're unfortunately
not the auto cue you sat there and
accused me of being an advert for the
Hitler Youth how do you justify that
well because that is downright offense
you're an absolute fascist right you you
you're a
particularly you sit here listen you sit
here this is actually a joke
you're an embarrassed country or
industry you're an embarrassment for
unions
justify yourself
and get paid thousands of points
I think you've dug your own grave yeah
well I think we'll move on thank you
very much
pleasure joining else I don't think it
has has it thank you